what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out to you
can help change the world so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
from rapper record producer and actor
Eminem and my take on his top ten most a
success vol 2 rule number four is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well enjoy
[Music]
he was often the only white guy
competing in underground clubs like this
one did you feed off the fact that
people maybe underestimated you or
didn't respect my family definitely I
think that uh you know it was there was
certainly like a rebellious like
youthful rage kind of in me and there
was also you know the fact of the the no
getting away from fact that I am white
you know and this is predominantly black
music you know and people telling me you
don't belong like you're not gonna
succeed because you're this color then
you want to sell those people did you
know that you can and you will
I want this attention for this music but
then I want to be able to go in public
and I want to be able to eat a sandwich
you know what I mean here and be left
alone so it was like man if I could
because I've never been an
attention-seeker and that seems like a
probably a hell of a career choice you
know but but I don't like at it like
like that's not why I do it is just to
get attention like I don't like to go in
public and walk around and be like Here
I am
you don't I mean like I don't it's not
what I want I just wanted my dream was
my dream was for like man to be able to
one day like hear rappers that I looked
up to on the radio and be like yo what
if jay-z who ever what if they heard of
me what if they thought I was dope you
know I'm saying like that was where my
mentality always was was was with it
well as far as who's a better freestyle
or between me and him I would definitely
have to say him I've never been really
good at freestyle and I've always been a
writer
although me this moment you'd probably
be a little rusty
like if somebody had just asked me to
freestyle it might sound like you know
it's one of those things like just like
picking up a basketball game picked one
up
in a year so you might be a little rusty
dribbling at first you don't saying so
it's one thing you got to get back on
the horse and ride that wasn't good
analogy right like a knife you don't to
keep sharp yeah it's like a knife you
got to keep chopping it you know if the
knife goals bill then you want to be
able to cut butter exactly well I think
he's trying to say that he can't cut
butter it's like a wall you got to keep
saving he writes his own songs and
delights in rhyming words others can't I
will start out slow we talked to him
about how he does it in his private
recording studio I've heard you said
that you bend the word yeah it's just in
the enunciation of it like people say
that the word orange doesn't rhyme with
anything and that kind of pisses me off
because I can think of a lot of things
that rhyme with orange what rhymes with
orange you're taking if you're taking
the word at face value and you just say
orange nothing is gonna run with it
exactly if you enunciate it and you make
it like more than one syllable
Orange you could say like I put my
orange 4-inch door hinge and storage in
a porridge with George you just have to
figure out the the science to breaking
down words and try to do you think about
this throughout the day I mean you're
driving along you think about rhyming
words yeah all day I actually drive
myself insane with it but it's a shame
it for a guy who hated school who you
know was in the ninth grade three times
and he you spend all your time thinking
about words I found it no matter how bad
I was at school like and no matter how
low my grades might events at some times
I always was good at English but I heard
that used to read the dictionary I just
felt like I want to be able to have all
these words at my disposal in my
vocabulary at all times whenever I need
to pull them out
you know somewhere they'll be stored
like locked away his words are stored
but they're not exactly locked away he
actually keeps them in boxes so you
store stuff than just in boxes like this
yes
inside are hundreds of scraps of paper
in which he's obsessively scroll down
words and phrases when this is a a pad
from a hotel in Paris looks like yeah
and you just scribbled that you have
four little words just yeah how do you
even read this this is I know what it
says I guess I might use it actually
they're not lyrics really they're just
ideas that he collects he calls it
stacking ammo so it's just like what I
some crazy people and they kind of look
like this yeah sometimes yeah I there
are all in capital letters or sort of
scrolling on pages like this yeah well
just probably because I'm crazy do us
post your hottest in every single way
and yet it's a city in America that's
going through the one of the toughest
times and then that must be kind of hard
to man you know the place where you grew
up is you know it's and it's in a bad
place that's in a bad way absolutely but
I think that it's the it's kind of you
know the Detroit mentality to to what
kind of the underdog I felt like we've
always been the underdog and that's kind
of how you know I've always taken that
it kept that with me you know saying
that that I want to say spite the
fighting spirit the Detroit has you know
because Detroit you know is so resilient
you know like like like I feel like are
like like people there we we have this
you know kind of Detroit vs everybody
mentality because I feel like people the
way that people look at us they always
count us out you know I'm saying so I
know that that attitude is displayed a
lot in my music but I think that that's
where it comes from is just from you
know just feeling like being like we're
being counted out
have the accolades to connect to the
performance of my music I don't have the
trophies that match how big the actual
records are the one Grammy I have is for
crack lobato
I couldn't even have that without him
you know that's why I have so much value
for him not just in my in my career just
in my life because he's a guy that one
of my best friends because I can trust
that he's gonna be honest with his
constructive criticism it's time to
listen to the music before it goes out
he's the only person that did things
that wanted to do he had the Marshall
Mathers LP with 23 million records so
with flags all over how an actual to
plaque and I was like y'all want that I
want that kind of success I know I had
to go toward the door to get it cuz I'm
not MC hip-hop is black music without
question and unfortunately for some
people is tough to accept you got a
white artist that does it better than
black artists is what it is you know and
you could put either one you could
whoever you feel like is the best black
artist and stand them face-to-face in a
room with him and he'll eat that alive
right now if you hadn't prepared
themselves in whatever way they would
have to prepare themselves to come to
battle and I bet you I bet what I have
everything I did that meatloaf we put
you right there and and and any other
competition that we will put these
artists in he's obviously surpassed them
my father first before anything I'm a
father before I'm a rapper so you know
my daughter comes first no matter what
and if there's important things going on
in her life that I need to be there for
then I'll drop what I'm doing or we
scheduled around it and a lot of times I
take her with me and you know she she's
been on the road with me before so she's
like smell like my little homey man like
she's like my little sidekick sometimes
it's hard like I'm not gonna front like
sometimes it gets hard to try to balance
them out but
I said before anything I'm a father I
always write you know and I probably
always will I don't know at what point
you know whatever point I decide like
I'm gonna put the mic down or whatever
happens with that I do feel like I'll
always want something to do with the
music so whether it's producing or
whatever you know ends up happening I
think that I just want something to do
with it you know music is always gonna
be in my head so I'm out myself that's
trapped in it
would you like to kind of work in cinema
and do more things like that exact
produce listen it depends on what it is
you know I'm I make music and whatever
comes along it seems like it might be
interesting or fun cuz at this point I
just want to have fun with it you know
like I just want to make sure that
whatever it is is something that I'm
passionate about and then I believe in
you know because otherwise just going
through the motions everybody in here
tonight who is an imminent Fame and I
just want to take a minute out to say
dating
for the support that y'all to show me if
you're not giving up hope you serious
thank you
especially to Detroit
SOLAS for you the songs are still deeply
personal but some of the hard edge anger
has softened in his new song not afraid
he offers a hand to those in need
hey everybody come take my hand we'll
walk this road together - ten years ago
could you have imagined yourself rapping
something like that probably not you
know I don't want to go overboard with
it a to view but i but I do feel like
that if I can help people you know I
can't stay but yeah he's got his baby
you neck he's got his face
myself I was in surgery recently reached
person the kind of person they get 80
cubic dickerson
maybe spirits of ladies concede he
murdered the virgins crazy turn today he
emerged to go over the world real didn't
know that you didn't
stills can kinda still like unit on
three pills the real slim James into the
film nothing but Rumble leaves and bio
reads up in this Mills ready filled with
it
we still shouldn't be here like there's
no one to sicken see and Caesar get free
casita like
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because fatale of Argus
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson are you going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leaving
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Dante Kors Dante thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word taking that picture in
your living room as you opened up the
book I really appreciate your support
and I hope you enjoyed the read thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
and what I wondered you know being
someone who is considered one of the
greatest of all time what is it about
rap the art form if you can even trace
it back to you when you first discovered
it to how you feel about it now I'm one
of your most rap heavy records and you
know just a lot of rap a lot of rapping
on there a lot of words what is it about
it that you love if you could put into
words hmm I don't know I I love the fact
that that you can I love the expression
of it the fact that you can you know
just I don't know I love the I love
beets and roms
and I love the fact that you can express
yourself in a rhyme and lay it down and
it's it can be therapeutic and you've
got it off your chest
and then you could go on to the next
thing I don't know there's so much that
I love about rap you know I'm in it for
like like I love to watch what's going
on in the game and keep my finger on the
pulse of that you know and it's exciting
to watch as a fan for me to you know
just being a fan of hip-hop and watching
is it you know did the evolution of it
and you know how it moves from each year
to year and the most important word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]